Speaker 1: Hey, here's an interesting
topic that came in via voicemail. You
can call the voicemail number any time two
one nine two David. Here's a question about
mixed status vaccination relationships,
whether they are friendships or whether
they are romantic relationships. Take a listen.
Speaker 7: Hey, David. My name is Caroline,
I currently live in Ohio,
but I'm from Connecticut.
Anyways, I wanted to ask you a question on. I
guess how to deal with personal relationships and
disagreements on vaccines, right? Well, I
have some friends that are not taking it, and
I'm actually currently in the process
of planning my wedding, which will be
not for a while. It'll be the end of 2022 if
everything goes right. But I'm wondering if it's
safe to invite them, but that it's going to cause
a big falling out if I don't. I'm just curious
how you would proceed if you were in my shoes.
Speaker 1: Yes. So I actually. So first of all,
on the topic of the mixed status relationship,
one person gets the vaccine and the other is
refusing. It seems like a no go to me, to
be perfectly frank. I don't know. It just
seems like if only one person is vaccinated as an
entity, as a couple, you're not really vaccinated.
The wedding question is an interesting
one. I'm invited to multiple weddings
and none of them are or are checking vaccine
certificates. But these are in the fall.
They've said, please don't come if you are not
vaccinated. And it's basically the honor system.
And I think they probably have an understanding
of people aren't going to lie. They'll understand
if they only want vaccinated people and I'm
not vaccinated, I'm simply not going to go.
So they've taken the approach of invite, but say
we are asking that everyone be vaccinated so that
we don't have to do masks and everybody can just
relax and have a good time. That's probably what
I would do. Let me know your thoughts. We've
also got a great bonus show for you today.
You can get instant access to it by becoming a
member at join Pakman dot com. I'll see you at.